[Music]
big holiday weekend you excited
[Applause]
well tomorrow night of course is the
jewish holiday of passover
that's right yeah
or uh or as we call it here in los
angeles cinco de mato
no no no it got exactly what it deserved
it was perfect
what else is going on mega millions
controversy getting stranger by the day
it's a very strange story yesterday the
maryland woman who claims she's the mega
millions winner held a press conference
where she not only failed to present the
winning ticket but also quickly asked
the press to leave
yeah
yeah in other words she's full of mega
[ __ ]
simple
now even though this woman claims she
won mega millions surveillance footage
shows the ticket was purchased by a man
yeah so either she's lying or we're all
trapped inside the new tyler perry movie
which i wouldn't mind ah it'll be fine
yeah let's only get to wear a dress uh
it's being reported that president obama
admitted he's a trekkie
you hear that he says he's attract is a
trekkie
which explains why the president is
polling very high with virgins age 45 to
60.
who would admit to that to a pollster
what being a virgin like i'm a 48 year
old virgin
they can just tell by what t-shirt
you're wearing
when you answer the door at your mom's
house
this week yahoo announced the firing of
2 000 employees
yeah in an effort to figure out just
what prompted the layoffs yahoo
employees spent hours googling the
answer
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my guy getting caught looking at
porn
you can see it this way too
that way you're the one catching me
great science news scientists have found
the remains of a large dinosaur covered
in a combination of feathers and fur
[Applause]
the yep inferred dinosaur was found in
china but reportedly had hopes of making
it to broadway
[Applause]
kanye west in the news kanye west has
recorded a new song in which he says he
has fallen in love
yeah kanye must be in love because the
song is entitled you remind me of me
[Applause]